distribuer un ruban un carrefour c'est
l'art de jongler entre les feux rouges
un ruban un petit geste qui doit dire
beaucoup ces rubans où ils sont là pour
dire stop à la une à l'indifférence cap
alinéa si on demande aussi à toute la
population d'avoir ou cherche au delà
dit au nom avec nous pour la seconde
fois de la semaine le collectif au foeil
epinoux se mobilisent à ce carrefour des
dizaines d'automobilistes sont
sensibilisés à la cause difficultés
qu'on a sur tous les sujets c'est que ça
se passe à la télé sur twitter mais que
les gens ne sont pas activement
mobilisés concrètement impliqué depuis
le début de l'année on compte 17 morts
en martinique le constat interpelle le
moment d'être j'ai mon beau-fils catch
attack in plusieurs fois avec plusieurs
mais c'est pas bon pour l'âme
entièrement moi on est un jeune ça me
donne pas envie de rester
la martinique c'est autre chose que ça
oui oui c'est une belle île on a
beaucoup de ressources
on a énormément patrimoine mais
malheureusement tout ça est entachée par
la violence le collectif demande plus de
policiers plus de moyens pour les
associations de quartier la vie publique
un champ à reconquérir ces examens
importants que les citoyens commencent à
s'investir dans l'action publique mais
dans l'intérêt collectif c'est à dire
que dans les écoles dans les
associations sur participer dans les
mouvements comme ça pour une position le
collectif auxerre et puis nous prévoit
une grande manifestation à la fin du
mois d'autres actions pour sensibiliser
et sortir de l'indifférence